we now know how to find the area of
rectangles what i want to do in this
video is think about how we can find the
areas of triangles so we're starting
here with a right triangle it has a 90
degree angle right over here right
triangle abc and let's think about how
we can find its area
well maybe we can construct a rectangle
out of triangle abc and if we can
construct a rectangle out of it and then
maybe we can somehow find our area of
part of that rectangle and the best way
to construct a rectangle is to really
duplicate abc and then flip it over and
put it right on top of this and just to
verify that that definitely will be a
rectangle so we know that this is 90
degrees right over here let's say that
this is x degrees right over there we
have x plus 90 plus this thing have to
be equal to 180 so this thing and this
thing have to add up to 90. so let's
just call this 90
90 minus x
now let's flip this thing and rotate it
around
so that it will look like this
so then you would have another triangle
that would look just like this
where now this right angle on the
flipped version is that right angle
right over there this angle right over
here this x is now this angle right over
there and this 90 minus x is now this
angle
right over there and you could see x
plus 90 minus x that'll give you a right
angle and then you have x plus 90 minus
x that gives you a right angle and you
have four sides and four right angles
you are definitely dealing with a
rectangle and this rectangle has two of
our original triangles in it so we can
write
we can write that the area
of triangle abc
the area of triangle abc that's what the
brackets mean area of triangle abc is
going to be equal to one-half times the
area of our entire rectangle and our
entire rectangle let me add another
point here let me call this d
it's going to be one-half the area of
rectangle a b
c
d
and we know how to find the area of
rectangle abcd it's going to be equal to
it's going to be equal to the base of
the rectangle so this is going to be
equal to
one half
times and so this part right over here
let me do this in a different color
the area of abcd is equal to the base or
the width of the rectangle so that's
just the length of bc i'm just putting
this in parentheses it doesn't mean it's
just bc is just the length of this
segment right over here and i'm just
putting it in parentheses so that we
don't get the letters jumbled up so it's
going to be this width or this base
right here times the height of the
rectangle so times a d
times sorry times a b
so it's this base times this height
gives us the area of the entire
rectangle and the area of our right
triangle is half of that so there we
have it it's one half times
times this base
times this height is the area of a right
triangle so in general if you ever have
a right triangle if you ever have a
right triangle
and this is a right angle right over
there which is you need one right angle
in order for me a right triangle and
this base has length b and this side
over here has length h you know that the
area
the area is going to be equal to one
half
times the base
times the base of the the of the
triangle that's the base of the triangle
bc
times the height of the triangle
so you could view it this way if you
look at the actual letter points and if
you just view these measures as a base
times the height it's just one half base
times height and we only know that this
works right now for a right triangle now
let's think about it for other types of
triangles that aren't necessarily right
triangles so here i have a kind of an
arbitrary triangle abc
and
to approach figuring out its area what i
want to do is just split this up into
two right triangles so what i'm going to
do is drop a perpendicular from b so i'm
going to just literally if this was if
this was an actual structure you just
literally drop something straight down
from here and that line is going to be
perpendicular to this base right over
here to ac and let me call that point
let me call that point d and what's
useful here is now we've constructed
we've we've turned that one triangle
into two right triangles so we can say
that the area
let me write it this way we can say the
area of triangle a
b c that's what we want to figure out
it's equal to
the area of this character right here
so it's equal to the area of triangle
abd
a
b d
plus
the area of triangle
plus the area of this magenta triangle
so plus
the area of b c d
of b
c d and this is useful because we know
how to find the area of right triangles
now obviously this is 90 degrees and
this is also going to be 90 degrees the
area of abd is one half base times
height so it's going to be one-half
times the base which is the length ad so
one-half times ad times the height which
is the length of bd right over here
assuming that we can figure that out so
this times that length
so bd so that's the area of the blue
triangle and now let's find the area of
the magenta triangle well once again
it's a right triangle it's going to be
one half i'll do that in magenta
let me do that in magenta so it's going
to be one half
times the length of this base right over
here which is dc
the length of segment dc times the
length of bd again
times the length of bd again now you can
factor out a one half
we can factor out a one-half bd from
both of these terms
one-half bd so you get one-half
bd
one-half bd times
a d
we're left with a d
and that's not the same shade of blue
we're left with
a d
plus d c
plus d c
plus
d c let me close the parentheses and
what is ad plus dc ad is the length that
length and then dc is this length so if
you were add up those two lengths you
get the length of ac
so this whole thing
this whole thing is the length ac so
we're left with the area of abc is equal
to i'll do this in a new color it's
equal to one half and i'll just switch
the orders right over here one half
times actually we're in that same color
times ac
ac times bd
times bd now what is this again well
this is now one half times the base
which is this ac times the height which
is bd so that's pretty cool it worked
for right triangles and it actually if
we know the height of a triangle notice
this isn't one of the sides now for a
right triangle it was one of the sides
now for this arbitrary triangle it isn't
but if we know it the area of this
triangle is still one-half times the
base times the height now what about a
triangle like this how can we figure out
its area
well let's try to do the same thing
let's see if we can somehow either
construct this out of right triangles or
maybe make add a right triangle of this
to make it into another right triangle
the easiest way to do that is we can
kind of just drop a rock from right over
there
and then this and then where it kind of
hits the ground would form a right angle
and let's call this point d
and what we care about what we want to
find in this
we want to find the area of we want to
find the area of triangle abc
so that's what we care about triangle
abc is what we want to find the area of
but the area of triangle abc is going to
be the area of this larger right
triangle that we've set up it's going to
be this larger triangle so it's going to
be the area of a d b
a
d b
minus the area of the smaller triangle
minus the area of this smaller one right
over here so minus
the area of adc
of a
d
c so i just this blue one a d b this is
just the whole thing
this is the whole thing just so we're
clear about what we're talking about now
what is the area of adb well we know how
to find the area of right triangles adb
area of adb is going to be
is going to be one half
times our base which is db
db
the length of segment db times our
height which is the length of a d
times a d and then from that we want to
subtract the area of the smaller
triangle so that's going to be one half
times our base
which is
dc that's the length of our base
dc times the length of our height which
is a d
a d
so here we can factor out a one half and
we can factor out an ad a one half and
an ad so let's do that so we factor out
a one half
times a d and what's left inside is a
db
db minus a dc
minus a dc now what is db minus dc let
me put the parenthesis in y2 again so we
have db
minus dc well if you take the length db
is the length of this whole thing you
subtract from that the length dc you're
going to be like left with cb
so this character right over here
this is c
this is cb and so the area of abc is
going to be equal to
one-half times cb i'm just switching the
order of multiplication
that yellow color
one-half times cb
times ad
times ad now what is this once again
it's one half times our base
times our base times our height and once
again the height in this case because
it's not a right triangle it's it's it's
not one of the sides someone would have
to give you that information you'd have
to figure out what this actual height is
but once what's neat is in any form of
triangle the area is one-half base times
height the height is kind of if you have
the sides of a right triangle it's it's
easy to figure out for these others if
it's not given you might have to do it
in some tricky way figure out figure out
the height somehow but anyway hopefully
you found that useful